Das ist eine, sagen wir, außerordentliche
Idee: Planet 9 ein Schwarzes Loch? Was wären
die Konsequenzen, wenn ein Schwarzes Loch
direkt in unserem Sonnensystem seine Bahnen
ziehen würde? Clixoom Science & Fiction.
Hier gibt es täglich faszinierende Wissenschaftsvideos.
Abonniert den Kanal nur dann verpasst ihr
nichts. Los Geht’s!
Herzlich willkommen! Es gibt kaum ein Thema,
dass die Astronomie mehr beschäftigt und
die Emotionen höher schlagen lässt. Seit
fast fünf Jahren wird Planet 9 gesucht. Gibt
es Planet 9 oder nicht oder ist er etwas ganz
anderes? Eine These (wir hatten darüber berichtet):
Ein Ring aus Abertausenden Objekten, die zusammen
die bis zu zehnfache Erdmasse hätten, hätte
zusammen den gleichen Effekt auf die Umlaufbahnen
zahlreicher transneptunischer Objekte kurz
TNOs, also Asteroiden und Zwergplaneten, wie
ein einzelner Planet. Bäm. Das sagt die Studie
von Jihad Touma von der American University
of Beirut und Antranik Sefilian von der University
of Cambridge aus. Planet 9 also nur ein Haufen
Steine? Oder eben doch ein Planet? Michael
Brown und Konstantin Batygin vom California
Institute of Technology (Caltech) haben tausende
Computermodelle durchgerechnet und bestätigt,
dass Planet 9 eben doch existieren könnte.
Auch das hatten wir schonmal als Video. Für
sie stehen die Chancen für Planet 9 500:1.
Er wäre demnach 400 Astronomische Einhieten
von der Sonne entfernt, Astronomische Einheiten
sind der Abstand zwischen Sonne und Erde.
Und er wäre bis zu fünf Mal größer als
die Erde. Und damit wäre er höchstwahrscheinlich
kein Gasplanet, sondern eine Supererde. Wow.
Theoretisch könnten wir dann irgendwann zu
ihm fliegen und auf ihm landen, wobei das
betreten eines Planeten mit einer solchen
Gravitation nur mit Exoskeletten möglich
wäre. So, aber jetzt. Das ist eine vollkommen
neue Idee! Was wäre, wenn Planet 9 kein Planet,
sondern ein kleines Schwarzes Loch wäre?
James Unwin, von der University of Illinois,
und Jakub Scholtz von der Durham University
haben diese These jetzt aufgestellt. Und das
würde wieder alles auf den Kopf stellen,
denn dann müsste ganz anders gesucht werden.
Bisher wird versucht Planet 9 erstmal aufgrund
der Bewegungsanaomalien der Transneptunischen
Objekte einzukreisen. Dann muss mit den unterschiedlichsten
Methoden, wie zum Beispiel die Lichtbeugung
von Sternen, die hinter dem vorbeifliegenden
Planeten liegen undsoweiter gesucht werden.
Doch die Wissenschaftler sagen: Es müsste
bei einem Schwarzen Loch ganz anders gesucht
werden: Sie vermuten eine Wolke von Dunkler
Materie um das Loch, die riesig sein könnte.
Materie und die Dunkle Materie würden in
diesem Bereich wechselwirken und das Schwarze
Loch verraten. Insbesondere Gammastrahlenblitze
könnten entstehen und diese könnten gemessen
werden. Es könnten also ganz andere Methoden
genutzt werden, wenn Planet 9 ein Schwarzes
Loch wäre. Die Wissenschaftler wollen jetzt
die Daten des Fermi-Weltraumteleskops genau
danach untersuchen. Denn das ist eine inzwischen
immer öfter verwendete Methode. Trainiere
eine Künstliche Intelligenz und lass sei
in alten Daten suchen. Bei Fermi liegen immerhin
Daten, seit mehr als 10 Jahren vor. Die Künstliche
Intelligenz soll jetzt nach Gammablitzen suchen,
die sich mit einer nahezu konstanten Geschwindigkeit
über den Himmel bewegen. Allerdings sind
sich die Wissenschaftler höchst unsicher,
ob sie Erfolg haben sollten bzw. Ob Planet
9 ein Schwarzes Loch ist. Sie wollen allerdings
die Astronomie Gemeinde dazu bewegen bei der
Suche kreativer zu sein und mehr Möglichkeiten
in Betracht zu ziehen. James Unwin dazu zum
Magazin Gizmodo: „Indem Sie sich schlicht
auf das Konzept eines Planeten konzentrieren,
schränken Sie die experimentelle Suche ein.
Sobald man anfängt, über exotischere Objekte
nachzudenken, wie etwa über primordiale schwarze
Löcher, denkt man anders. Wir befürworten,
dass nicht nur im sichtbaren Licht nach ihm
gesucht wird, sondern auch in der Gammastrahlung.
Oder in kosmischer Strahlung.“ Was passiert
in einem Schwarzen Loch? Anklicken, anschauen
und Doktor Whatson abonnieren.